hello and welcome back to the end game
class as always my name is caleb denby
and today i'm gonna be walking you
through some really interesting
positions
involving a rook against a bishop and i
actually
have a book with me here today that i've
been reading in my spare time
this is volume two of comprehensive
chess endings by averbach uh and this is
the book
that inspired me to go over these
positions here today
and when that book says comprehensive
let me tell you
it is comprehensive uh so i took some
interesting positions from it
and hopefully i'm going to consent to
condense it down
to the important bits for you here today
uh like i said
the theme is the rook against the bishop
in the pure end game so let's start off
as simple
as it gets here we do have of course
a rook against a bishop and if you know
some things about this end game
with no pawns on the board it is tending
to be
a draw with a few exceptional
circumstances
so i wanted to start off showing why it
is a draw
the drawing idea here for
black involves actually putting the king
in the corner that is the opposite color
as the bishop and while that might not
seem intuitive
at first of course the idea is that the
bishop
is able to sort of guard the king from
the two squares next to the corner
this is the drawing idea and so no
matter
where white goes black will simply
stay on this long diagonal here always
keeping an eye on b8
eventually white is going to get bored
and play rook f8 check
when after bishop b8 white of course has
no way to improve his position here
without stalemating
uh black if for g8 this position is
stalemate
if the king backs up then king b7
check came back to a8 came back to a6
and look at that we've been here before
uh
and so this is why this position is
generally a draw
for uh for black he's able to keep the
bishop on this diagonal
and guard against the checkmates using
this bishop coming back to b8
and of course this works for any corner
as chess
is a symmetrical game but now let's
examine
the one or two exceptional circumstances
that would uh would allow white to win
the game
and i'll talk to you a little bit later
on about why it's actually important to
know these
so of course this is the safe corner
that you
as you can tell because it's opposite
the color of the bishop
and what happens if the king gets put
in the unsafe corner the corner that is
the same color as the bishop
well what happens is he quite often gets
checkmated
so here we see a very very similar
position with the notable
exception that the bishop is now the
same color
as the corner so
with white to move chat room of course
how would white
win this game white to move how do you
win
how do you win if it is white move this
is about as simple as the puzzles are
going to get for tonight
so yeah rookie seven uh so sorry i
actually have the position set up with
black to move because it's a little bit
more interesting but let's triangulate
here
uh rookie seven would do it uh the
bishop has to
guard against checkmate and also not die
so king see it of course white would
just capture the bishop
but if you go bishop g6 then rook g7 is
going to win
this bishop can come back to f5 with the
same
defensive idea that we've seen before
but now after rook g8 check bishop c8
the unfortunate news for black is his
pieces are not shifted
one square to the left so after a
passing move by
whites this is not stalemate black is
forced to play king a8
and then white can win the bishop on c8
so that's the general
winning idea here for white is
you keep the king boxed in the corner
and then you're able to
draw the rook away with a threat to the
bishop and also a threat of checkmate
and black is
unable to deal with both of these
threats at the same time
now in the initial position what do you
guys think
would be the most resistance here for
black how can black
put up a fighting resistance in this
case to try not to lose the game
immediately
then let's see if you can see how white
might win anyways
so now the position is black to move
black to move here
what has changed what can black possibly
try
to not lose the game
so yeah there's only one move on the
board that actually keeps the game going
if black passes on this diagonal white
has the same winning idea
if something like bishop b7 then of
course this is hanging
if bishop a8 that doesn't really help
now the rook to any of these squares
is winning because of the skewer
uh so bishop b1 must be played
why does this move put up a little bit
of resistance well now of course
if the rook tries to leave he can no
longer gain a tempo against the bishop
and the king could escape and that would
actually be a draw if the king manages
to get out
so how do we win with white here well
the idea
is of course quite simply to draw the
bishop out from behind the king
so you have this idea of playing rook c1
to challenge this bishop
the bishop can come to a2 notably if it
goes anywhere
along this diagonal it gets met by the
rook
chasing it with the same idea of
checkmate to follow
bishop g6 rook g1 bishop f7
and sorry rook f1 would be a bit simpler
coming to f8 now with checkmate so rook
c1 the only move for black is to play
bishop
a2 now of course if rook a1 the
we are not threatening checkmate but
rook a1 is still useful to draw the
bishop further away
now once again if something like bishop
c4
how do we win well
the c file isn't quite the same as the
other files for the bishop
because now once again white can
threaten checkmate
what's the difference here well the
difference is if king c8
the bishop is on the c file and white is
able to win it
all of that is to say of course the the
ideas are the same
if something like bishop d5 the rook can
go to the same file as the bishop
and find its way to the back rank with
mate so bishop b3
is the only option and now unfortunately
after the move rook a3 the bishop cannot
go
anywhere on the a file and it cannot
stay on the b file
which means it is forced either to a
square
where the rook can threaten both the
bishop and come to the back rank with
checkmate
some lightning fast arrow drawing or
it's forced to come to the c file
and we have the same winning idea that
we just saw with the root coming back to
c3
to uh to pin if necessary and so all of
that is to say
when the king gets put in the wrong
corner like this
and we have him trapped there white can
always
win the game and that is very very
useful
to know why is that useful to know well
we'll see
that sometimes white uh can use this
idea
to transpose from a position with a pawn
still on the board
to a winning pure rook versus bishop end
game and so it is
useful to know this there's one more
checkmating position that i wanted
to show off here and that is a position
like this
so this is a position where
we have the kings opposite each other
and it is white to move of course if it
were black to move here
black would be able to draw by running
away with the king
towards uh well just running away with
the king not running all the way
to the wrong corner but running far
enough to not have
checkmate being threatened immediately
so for example
let's just prove it so black to move
here king e8
is the draw running away if king e6
then king d8 running further away now if
king d6 well you aren't making much
progress anymore
if uh sorry so king d8 if this move
with check now both king c8 and king e8
are still drawing but we'll do king c8
for simplicity's sake
and now of course the key point is that
after this check
sorry the key point is that after this
check
we do well sorry king d8 here would
actually be a mistake because this move
wins
okay this wasn't supposed to be the main
point this always happens to me in these
tricky end game positions
maybe king e8 would actually be a bit
simpler here the idea being now we can
check this king
off of this square which is threatening
checkmate to our own king all right
final answer
uh if something like rook d2 then bishop
g4 check is the simplest
and checkmate is no longer being
threatened so white cannot win
anyways the initial position uh this is
an important one to remember
and when i say that i don't mean this
position specifically
i mean pretty much any position where
the kings are standing opposite
each other and white has the potential
to threaten a checkmate with the rook
on the back rank these are positions
that white
can be winning in and it's also
important to remember this
so what is the winning idea for white
i'll give you guys at home
a moment or two to try and find it
likely the first move is going to be
rather obvious and we can sort of just
take it move by move here so how do we
start
so yeah the the first move i'm seeing is
rook e7
and of course rook e7 is actually in
the wrong direction because now after
king g8 black
is uh very very close to achieving this
wrong corner defense
king g6 would now allow the only move to
draw
bishop c6 if we go here
threatening the bishop and checkmate
there's a check
and at the end of the day we do
get to our famous corner if rook
e6 then anywhere on this diagonal
still keeping an eye on this preparing
to check the king next turn
and black is going to be able to set up
so what's the first move so yes of
course the first move
is in fact rook g3 it's the same idea we
need to evict this bishop
from behind our king so we can attack
both the bishop
and checkmate at the same time now the
game ends very quickly
if you come somewhere like bishop d5 the
simple rook d3
with checkmate to follow or at least
we've seen this idea before king has to
move we take the bishop
so the most resilience is to stay on the
e file
because then of course this is not
checkmate and here the move rookie 3
is good enough the bishop now should
still try and stay
on these files next to the king to avoid
the immediate checkmate
once again something like bishop h5
means rook h3
and here we can even pass with the king
all of that is to say
that the bishop has to stay on these
three files or else
it will die so bishop c4 rookie 3
bishop g2 and now after rookie 2
and bishop back to f3 the incredible
move here
to win for white who sees the winning
idea
to get rid of this bishop
who sees how we can kill this bishop
who sees it i'll say yes hello
to adi in the chats hello to joe
rook b2 is possibly being suggested
rick b2 i don't see the idea i think
it's another situation where the black
king might be able to escape
either towards the center or towards the
wrong corner
for example rook b8
is check king h7 though
not sure where the threat is
so yeah the the last move of course is
rook f2 and this
is quite a tragic circumstance
for the black pieces uh of course in
order to draw the bishop
has to stay on these three files uh
these three squares
are obviously guarded and these two
squares are
indirectly guarded by the discovered
check with
the king and in fact there's no way to
avoid this circumstance
for black in this case
and so once again black would end up
having to move the bishop away
then we move the rook to the same file
threaten checkmate and the bishop
and win the game
okay so those are the two main winning
positions that i want to show and of
course there are other
you know special cases but i think these
are the two most important
uh knowing that you can win when the
king is in the wrong corner
and knowing that you can win when you
have uh the kings opposite each other
like this
with the bishop on the the opposite
colored square as the king
the bishop were on the same colored
square as the kings
let's say for example we had
let me make it white to move oops that's
not good
we had this position uh then actually
i guess these positions are still
winning because
you can force the king
in this manner and then you have the the
same position
um okay that would have been an
interesting puzzle to include but i
wanted to highlight
that this winning method works because
the kings are on the opposite color as
the bishop
if the kings are over one square
like we could see here
oops someday i'll get there
then uh white can still win by virtue of
this rook e7 move
with king if king f6 to follow i think
though if the bishop were over here
then this this wouldn't be winning
anymore because black could could run to
the square that was only winning
because i put the bishop on a square
where it could be captured after king f6
so the point is to say this position is
important to know
kings opposite each other black king on
the back rank and
the uh the bishop on the other color
no matter where this bishop is by the
way if this bishop were over here
somewhere
obviously then it's it's a simpler win
so no matter where the bishop is
for black in this case when you can
achieve this setup
and it's your turn you are able to win
the game
because you can evict this bishop from
behind your king
okay also unsafe corner those are the
two winning positions
so now i want to move on to a slightly
more
complex position so of course without
the pawn
these positions are always drawn now
because the king is not in one of those
special circumstances
but white has white has a pawn so white
should expect to be able to win this
game so i wanted to ask you guys at home
what your immediate thoughts were on
how to go about winning this position
for
white how can you try to win this one
no need to memorize it really yes so you
don't have to memorize it
uh you don't have to memorize the
winning technique just try
and understand that when the king's in
the wrong corner you should have some
way to win
then you should be able to find it and
when the kings are opposite each other
like that
you uh can win with with the same idea
you attack the bishop and and threaten
checkmate at the same time
and can force the bishop to a square
where you can do that
so two people in the chat room say d5
one person says e5
i bet they mean d5 rook c1 has been
suggested
king in front says joe bruno pushing the
king to the back rank immediate thought
is to push the pawn
is it good to try to trade rook for
bishop and go for king and pawn versus
king
so a lot of you guys are making a
big mistake as mike cummer would say
d5 check is still a winning position but
it makes the king
the it makes the win sort of absurdly
more difficult
than with the pawn on d4 and so i'm
going to explain why that is in just a
second
but first of all when you get into any
position like this
almost in any general end game and
especially in these end games where you
have the rook
uh the position is much easier to win
in all rook end games when your king is
in front of your own pawn
if the king is behind your own pawn and
the enemy king is in front of it
becomes much more difficult to win so
priority number one here for white
is not to push his pawn up the board
priority number one for white is to push
his
king up the board and so with d5
you make that task much harder because
your king no longer has access to the d5
square
so it's going to be more difficult to
push the king so of course
the uh easy way to win these positions
is to use the rook as a long range piece
and push back the enemy king from the
sides of the board
so you could go to a1 or you could go to
h1 here
personally h6 is a dark square
so i would choose a1 because our
opponent's bishop is a dark square
bishop
so rook a1 is a great way to start the
bishop might pass for example
we can give rook a6 check bishop back to
d6
and now the simple pass and there's
nothing to do here for black
but seed some ground king d5
and you start to see the the downfall
of the black pieces here
yeah king c6 for example and now
with the king out in front this is a
trivial win
we can checkmate using the king and pawn
against the king
or simply queen our pawn by force
so this is a very very easy win for
white
in most cases when the pawn is back that
far and your king is not behind it
then it's a pretty trivial win however
i do want to talk about this position
because not
you won't necessarily always have your
king in front of the pawn
so let us talk about the position after
d5 king d7
is the way to go for black here you want
to keep the king in front of the pawn
and now how do you win this position for
white
there should be two squares that are
very important
in your mind two crucial squares
that will change the outcome of the game
so two squares
that would allow you to make progress
what squares are those
what squares are those
so the position is still winning it's
just a very difficult win
so a lot of different ideas are being
thrown around
the closest i saw in the chat was e6 and
c6
of course if you can get your king to
those squares then you win the game
but actually in order to make progress
you want the king beside the pawn
right we saw in this position the king
beside the pawn we control all these
squares
we can bring the rook to the side and
then advance our king very very easily
so after the move d5 these are the two
squares that become important
if we get the king beside our pawn and
it's able to stay there notably not
immediately be checked away
then we can use the rook to force the
king back advance our king and win the
game
so e5 and c5 are the squares that you
need
in order to win this game there's really
no other way to force a win here
unless you can force your king to one of
those two squares
and it's not as easy as you might think
to uh to achieve this so a lot of you
guys had some really good ideas
to start attacking from the sides of the
board so let's start with the move
rook g1 for example right the opponent
is likely going to
play this bishop somewhere no reason to
move this king back and forth
and so for example after bishop a5 you
can give
maybe two checks and the question is
now how do you ever get the kings the
king to e5 or
c5 well king d4 might be a reasonable
start
forking both squares but bishop e1
and you can start to us you can start to
see how it's actually going to be very
very annoying
to get your king into one of those
squares
because if you ever step to c5 bishop f2
check
maintains the position and if you step
every step to e5 bishop c3 check
maintains the position
and this is going to be the drawing
technique now for
black so i want to ask you guys
you know you might be thinking to
yourself wait a second what's
what's the big deal what's the big idea
here
you know you keep saying this nonsense
about having to push my king
to e5 or c5 but but come on caleb you
just play d6
you play king d5 next or you run the
king up
you win the game what's the big deal
so my question chat is black to move
after d6 and it is in fact black to move
and draw and this is the
key defensive idea that
black can use to maintain the position
here
black to move and draw in this position
bishop b4 has been suggested
king c6 has been suggested
and yeah bishop b4 is not enough because
king d5
and rook uh g7 to follow or of course
rook h6 to h7 to follow
but king c6 is surprisingly
a dead dead draw there's nothing
white can do here to advance this pawn
any further
or in fact to even keep this pawn king
e5
and the key idea now is you don't allow
king e6
by playing the move bishop b4 king e6
now would mean bishop takes d6
and you have nothing better to do with
your time then pass back and forth
forever
or eventually blunder your rook to
bishop c3 check with a draw so
that is the key point this is why pawn
d6
is almost never never going to be
winning
for white in these positions and the
idea holds true
if we go forward a little bit in this
position here
king d4 and the bishop can come back to
b4
right so this is always going to be
good enough for black one more position
here actually with the bishop on such a
bad square this would be winning because
there's no way to stop this you can't
detect the pawn
i was trying to highlight that in like
every case it's a draw
for black but it is only a draw if the
bishop can come back
to b4 or i think to b8
or even f8 if it is black or if it is
white if it is f8 sometimes it depends
on whose turn it is i don't remember
whose turn but
f8 usually doesn't come into play it's
usually this square
b4 or that square b8 so let's take a
look at it with the bishop on b8 for
example
um let's say
this happens d6
now king c6
okay well i keep doing a bad job
sorry okay here d6
uh king c6 and i'm still doing a bad job
because i'm hanging my bishop
the point is this position is also a age
raw
if it is black to move in this case you
can't pass with the bishop but you can
pass with king to c5
i was just struggling to get it set up
so once again after bishop a5 we go all
the way back here
and the point is d6 is a draw in these
positions
thanks to king c6 followed by bishop b4
with pressure on the pawn
so instead white has to try very very
hard to win this game
king d4 for example bishop e1
and now believe it or not the only three
the only four moves that make progress
are richie eight are these four moves
these are the only ones that make
progress
and the reason is you want to have your
opponent place his king
onto the d6 square and then you want to
go
rook g2 and the point is as in the other
cases
you want to start taking away these
squares from the enemy bishop
the downside is it's just so much more
difficult when the bishop has so many
squares
so now if something like bishop h4 the
game ends very quickly
rook g6 check and we get to one of our
key squares
right the bishop can't check us off so
we would win
the most resilience by black is bishop
b4
and now after rook g6 check king d7 we
can't go king e5 because of bishop c3
we can't go king c5 because that square
is defended
and if something like king c4 then
you're asking for a repetition here
okay so for
example in this position now the best
way to play
is rook g6 check king d7 and believe it
or not we need to waste another tempo
now
with rook h6 which i know seems a little
bit absurd
if black tries to pass with the same
ideas now we go rook
h1 and after bishop f2
we go king e4 king d6 for example
and rook f1 is the idea now bishop h4
and rook g1 is the idea now if bishop
f2 we go check and we made to our square
so you can kind of see how it's
ridiculously difficult
to win these positions so rather than
go through every possible continuation
by black here
the point is it can be done if you
absolutely have to do it
and the way to do it is to take away
these squares from the bishop
and eventually you are able to sort of
break free
but if at all possible you should try to
avoid it because like bishop g3 is also
playable then rook g1
bishop can come back to c7 check again
check again king d4 but like
bishop f4 and you see it's it's just so
complicated man like i can't
describe to you how complicated it is
rook g2 to take away squares
bishop back to b8 but now rook g7 check
and all of a sudden you've interfered
with the coordination between your
enemies pieces
bishop c7 g6 king c5
and you got to one of the squares then
as for how you win from here
of course it's the same as before you
just uh
evict the king and put your king in
front of your pawn
moral of the story is don't push your
pawns willy nilly
in rook end games push your king instead
and it will be much better
so any questions about this in
particular
obviously it's a lot of specifics and a
lot
of
sorry a lot of you know taking it move
by move taking away squares from the
bishop and it's
it looks a little bit complex and sort
of arbitrary
but you know the method is is just
taking away squares from the bishop and
trying to put your opponent into a
zugzwang
so the bishop has to move to a
sub-optimal square
allowing your king through but any
questions on this
any potential winning ideas that you
think i didn't mention
any potential drawing ideas that you
think i didn't mention
can't you just trade the rook for the
bishop so of course
that is a key idea to try and
go for winning king and pawn on games
but of course with the king behind the
pawn the enemy king in front of the pawn
this end game is just a draw hopefully
most of us know this one
stalemate
um okay well then
everybody loves center pawns why not
talk about
the bishop pawns as well um
so once again the win is trivial here
if you push the king first rook h1
bishop g4 rook h6 king
c7 king c5 and the win
is trivial check
and push push push push push easy peasy
right
but once again now if you push the move
c5 the win is going to be
very very difficult once again and
the idea is is going to be the same uh
you need to push the bishop out from
from controlling these two key squares
so just to quickly go through some of it
king c7 for example
rook h1 bishop a4
king c4
this just to give you an idea of what it
might look might look like
rook e6 actually ends up being a key
move here of course if the position were
flipped it would be rook d6
because the move or the the e2 square
ends up being really important for the
bishop so now for example if
bishop d1 we could go king b5
so rook e6 in a sense has prevented the
move bishop d1 by controlling e2
which leaves bishop c2 as the only good
pass for
black now after rookie 2 if bishop d1
we would have rookie 7 check and the
same idea here
if king over there then we can win the
bishop
so king c7 king b5 so not bishop d1 but
bishop back to a4
notably if the bishop goes this way we
are
able to step to this square the bishop
goes to g6
then we have this idea
so bishop a4 is best now rook a2
and if the bishop steps to d1 uh once
again
we are controlling e2 so the bishop has
to go back to e8
and we are chasing this bishop all over
the board
rook h7 now is the best move and yeah
this one
i'm even struggling with there's bishop
f7 check because this is stalemate
that's wild
but king b4 should be good enough bishop
back to e8 rook h6 check
king c7 and now after king
a5 we are actually able to invade here
bishop c6 for example
means rick h7 check and king b7
means rook over to e6
with the same idea bishop h5
would mean c6 check
and now we have one of those situations
where black
is unable to prevent ricky seven check
to follow unable to play
uh king b6 at b for the drawing idea
obviously that's not playable
in this position so just giving you an
idea of how crazy complicated those
positions are
however i have good news for you while
those four pawns
are stupid hard to win with knight pawns
are a little bit different
so if you find yourself in a very
similar situation
with the knight pawn there is actually a
much easier winning idea
and this is why at the top of the hour i
showed you those
basic winning positions in the pure
rook versus bishop end game and you can
use those
to your advantage if you find yourself
in a position with
a knight pawn like this so now
we've already given up uh
we've already played the move b5 and so
previously
with the bishop pawns and the center
pawns we would have to get our king to
one of these two squares
right that was the only way to make
progress however in this case there's
one more
so let's play a few moves that are just
natural rook g1 for example
of course of king c5 here there's bishop
b6 so rook g1
bishop f4 rick g7 check rook
g6 check and now i'll present it as a
puzzle to you guys
white to move and make significant
progress
white to move and essentially win the
game on the spot here
what do you guys got what you got
white to move and win
so obviously like every move wins
besides like
you know hanging stuff but uh
so yeah the chatroom has it so the idea
is b6 and the chat room said and king b5
but if you remember
king a6 was drawing the game this was
the drawing idea that we saw for the
bishop pawns and the rook pawns
if you try to push this pawn too early
without the king there to support it
then you get met with this idea
king steps down and bishop here to
follow
so what's the uh what's the big idea you
guys what's the big idea here
what's the what's the big idea
why is this one winning still for
white well of course
sorry my phone shut off so i'm reading
the chat
the idea is you go king c5 this bishop
checks you king c6 this bishop takes
your pawn for free
but ah aha what's this this is starting
to look
familiar starting to look a little bit
familiar is it
not and so of course this
is very similar to this position that we
saw
we have the kings opposite each other
and are able to
checkmate the enemy king so back here
the easy checkmate is to go rook g2
and now do the unfortunate placement of
this bishop
white is simply winning king a5 for
example
rook a2 check and takes
if pass or k2 check
and we've seen this one before right
so this b6 move is actually a very easy
way
to win if you do have a knight pawn not
a bishop pawn or center pawn
interesting stuff so knight pawns easy
peasy doesn't matter what you do
okay let's look now at the
rook pawn briefly as well so this
is uh basically all i'm doing
is pushing this pawn and all the pieces
over one file with
each new position that we look at so
let's check it out with with the rook
pawn now with the rook pawn
already on the fifth rank so what are
some winning ideas here
well once again we can resort to
bringing the rook over to a square like
g1 and bringing the king up now
to some place like c5 notably if king
a6 king b4 defends for the moment
give this check and now king of c5
so we bring the rook up to the side and
then advance our king
and what's the point here black can sort
of stubbornly try
and defend this guy so white to move and
win
once again white to move and win here
what is on the minds of the lovely chat
room
okay people are saying king b5 i don't
i don't understand don't understand
maybe they were saying that earlier
so yeah a6 is once again the winning
idea but you have to be careful
it's a free pawn how do you win this
position
how do you win this position you gave up
your you gave up your pawn dude what are
you doing
that was your pawn your pawn's dead now
why'd you let your pawn die
why did you let your pawn die
so if king c6 and something like bishop
c4 for example
how are you winning
rest in peace everybody type press f in
the chat for the pawn you let him die
it was your pawn there's your boy it's
your baby queen right there
it's gone so the easy way to win
is in fact rook f7 check king b8
and we can actually come to b6 with
tempo on the bishop
and uh white is now of course
threatening
checkmate and to take the bishop as well
uh you astutely noted that king c6 is
actually winning as well
why is that well it's because we have
the king trapped in
the wrong corner and so we know that
these positions are
winning how do we know that they're
winning because we've uh
seen the winning idea here right we have
to evict
the bishop from these spaces behind our
king
we can do so with rook g6 bishop
h7 for example rick g7
and bam we take the bishop
if here rook g7 and it's the same idea
just rotated so the bishop can't go to
any of these squares
if it goes here we've seen this idea
before so you see how useful it is
to know those basic basic end games
where if you have the kings opposite
each other or the king in the wrong
corner
you can win because then that means
you don't have to remember how to win
this god-awful position
you just push a6 you're like you're in
the wrong corner stupid
all right now i have changed the
position slightly
i have changed the position slightly and
so
this one uh the bishop
is now not the same color as the corner
square
and what does that mean well that means
that this position is actually just
a dead draw even with the extra pawn
even with the extra pawn
with black in front of the pawn the
position is
just easily drawn you can check
bring the king up but this bishop's
going to pass here forever
after a6 once again the bishop just
passes
on this diagonal doesn't let this pawn
advance we can check but king a8
king c6 does nothing we continue to pass
if a7 the simple captures
if a7 here captures here
then bishop b8
is drawing the game if this rook
well bishop d4 also draws the game here
i should say but
if i had this rook on a slightly better
square for example
then bishop b8 would be the key point
here
and the bishop has made its way to the
defensive diagonal
we can't go rook g8 because it's a
stalemate and the game
is a draw so i did want to highlight
that that if the bishop
is the opposite color as the corner you
must must
must must get the king in front of your
pawn first
because many of these positions are just
dead drawn
so what have i shown so far
i've shown the pure positions and i've
also shown
that it's easy to win if you get your
king laterally
with your pawn here and i've shown that
it is winnable but it is very difficult
to win
if you push the pawn in front of your
king on the fifth rank
now while this position is very very
complex
i have some good news for you all right
this is
you know sort of your your break for the
lecture here right
you know all those positions where your
king was stuck behind the pawn with the
pawn so far advanced were like
crazy difficult the good news is if your
pawn
is on the fourth rank or below the win
is actually
much much simpler and what's the reason
for that
what do you guys think what does the
pawn being less far
advanced actually do for us why is the
win
easier here and that might actually lead
you to the winning method
so what makes this win much easier
just get the king up to just get the
king up dude just get the king up just
all those other positions too just get
the king up right
so we have our key squares right we have
our key squares and in the previous
positions we had to go
this way with the rook and then for
example
you know try and get our king over but
it was always
rather difficult right you check from
the side but king e3
you check again and it seems like we
actually have less space to work with
to get our king out if you start going
king c2
you might live to regret it uh bringing
your king over this way is actually not
making any progress right
not making much progress at all here
uh okay so why is the win easier
what's different
king f2 you get checked right you get
checked
and once again once again it's not so
easy
not so easy
so yeah the fact that the pawn can go
one or two squares actually doesn't make
a difference here because we want our
king in front of the pawn
we don't want the pawn to go we want our
king to go
um so it's actually a pretty tricky idea
here
the idea is in these positions
the king is controlling these three
squares right the squares
immediately around the king are all
controlled so we have to have to have to
check the king from the side and it
turns out
that when the pawns are not so far
advanced we can in fact
check the king from behind and this
turns out to be
really useful because when we check the
king from behind like this
we force it to pick a side leaving one
of the other sides sort of
under defended and in addition to that
our rook does a great job of defending
our pawn so we don't have to worry so
much about that as well
so for example bishop g3 check king d2
check i'll even play king back to d1
let's say bishop g5
we check from behind black has to pick a
side
and then we go the other way
and are easily winning the game bishop
f4 for example
king f2 this should be five uh here we
could even capture i guess but let's say
a better move we bring the king up right
does this make sense
king is easily brought in front of the
pawn here
so we check from behind whenever
possible wasn't possible at first
because our pawns were too far advanced
but it is possible here let's take a
look now at
a similar position which i didn't bother
to input let's just move all the pieces
back
yeah here for example
and yeah white to move here so once
again
with the pawn on the fourth rank for the
moment we can't advance the king up
because
black is still controlling those squares
but we do still have this opportunity to
actually check the king
from behind and this turns out to be
very relevant notably if the king tries
to step up here
we are very happy to bring the rook away
actually bring the rook away with tempo
on the bishop the bishop moves
and then we are invading
uh notably here also g8 king of seven
this one is going to be a w
for white
so even when the pawn's on the fourth
rank you can go back to this idea of
checking from behind it's just the most
apparent with this pawn all the way back
here
okay any questions on this idea of
checking from behind because this is a
really useful idea
really useful
all right storm we'll get to that in
just a bit analyze your games of course
is coming up
right after this on twitch um
okay so checking from behind really
useful
so what have we gone over now we've gone
over the pawns
on all these ranks when they're back
here you check from behind
easy win we've gone over the pawns on
the fifth ranks
the fifth rank when the king is in front
of the pawn of course easy win beside
the pawn easy win
when the pawns in front of the king not
so easy right not
so easy except in the case of the knight
pawn and the rook
pawn when the bishop is the wrong color
or the right color i don't know
but now let us look finally at the pawn
on the sixth file
so with the pawn on the sixth file
once again the position is going to
be winning in some cases not
going to be the case in other cases in
other cases makes sense right
uh so with the pawn on the central file
actually the the win is still going to
be rather difficult here
we have bishop f2 for example just
passing
rook d7 check means king e8
and once again we're going to have to do
this dance of trying to fight against
the enemy bishop to get our king to one
of these squares right taking away
squares bit by bit by bit
bishop a3 rook a2 bishop back to b4
or k4 this check would allow king d6 so
bishop e1 now
but now rookie 4 and yeah things get a
little bit
a little bit crazy bishop c3 check but
king d6
and you can see we finally won the
battle right we finally got our king
up to uh up to the square and now
if you want to score style points you
play king e6 here
and we've seen this win before right
we've seen this win before
so it's all about getting the pawn up to
the seventh rank once again
in fact actually is there an easier one
here i think there might be
so for example let's go to b1 because i
want to aim for a light square
we give this check king d8 and we can
actually play the move e7 here
and what's the idea after um
after king f7 what's the win here with
the pawn
on the sixth rank if you don't want to
do the dance then you have to be able to
find the win
here so white to move and win in this
position
i mean the sixth rank i don't know what
i said but i meant the sixth drink
upon sacrifice and king e6 not quite
not quite you give up this pawn king
here
king e6 king d8 going towards
the safe corner not the unsafe corner
that we know and love and it is a draw
so the only move to win here the only
move to win
play any other move if you waste a turn
bam bishop c5 i take this guy
game's a draw the only move to win is
rook d7 why is this the only move to win
well
because now he goes to the unsafe corner
of course if he wastes time with the
bishop we can evict
this bishop from behind our king
everybody loves this tactic everybody
loves this tactic we've seen it a
million times before now
and so king f8 is the only try
but now what move do we have we have
rook
f7 check if king he ate
we fork if king g8
now the only move to win we want to
achieve
this position so the only move to win
is king f6 and king g6 and we have our
opponent checkmated
so you can still fall back on these
checkmating ideas
when the pawn is advanced to the sixth
rank
okay let's check out the bishop file now
and
the bishop file when the pawn is on the
sixth rank like this
and the opponent has blockaded this one
is actually
just a dead draw so bishop's pawns
kind of the worst kind of the worst uh
and the reason is with the pawn on the
fifth rank
we were still able to win because the
diagonal for defense was actually i
believe
one uh one square shorter
on behind the pawn and now with the pawn
on the sixth
white or black has just a little bit of
extra maneuvering room to maintain the
blockade here
and what happens if we fall back on this
plan
of check and
advancing this pawn well the point is
that in the other position black could
not
always keep a hold of this uh this
square
whereas here he can if f7 then black to
move
and draw in this position black to move
and draw
black to move and draw
so i don't want to spend too much time
i've only got five minutes left of
course
king g7 not taking here falling for the
trap
don't fall for the trap we know this one
but king g7
and now the point is after f8 queen
king f6 we can go to the safe corner
and draw the game
game draw alright
now let's lastly look at the knight file
and then i have a funny position that i
want to show you so here
once again you can go rookie 7 check
king g8
g7 and king h7 is not enough
to draw because we can
go back to this drawn position that we
already know rick f7
queen king
stuck in the wrong corner right
everybody knows it
and then the position i want to end on
is a position
uh by troytsky back in 19 or 18
not not 19 1898 he found this position
and believe it or not this position is
white to move
and draw the game so of course this is
wildly different than anything
we've seen so far of course in any
position where the white king is so far
away
from the pawn it should generally always
just be an easy win for black
but not so here white to move and draw
the game
what do you guys think to end on
danilo says so the secret is to have the
pawn on the same color of the opposite
bishop before you reach the sixth rank
no the idea is you never have to worry
about any of that if you get your king
in front of the pawn
just get your king in front of the pawn
first right if you're in
a position where you can worry about
those things
then worry about getting your king in
front of the pawn first
um otherwise if you're forced into some
position where your pawn's already
so far advanced and your kings behind it
then that's when you need to start
worrying about this this other stuff
okay there's some ideas in the chats
king a5 suggested bishop d5 check
suggested
so let's think about it here let's think
about it right
how does black win the game well if
white steps to
a file that is not in quote unquote the
king's
shadow those of you out there king
shadow
anybody know that term then of course
black checks
and queens the next turn
unstoppable right so white's idea of
course is going to be
to stay in the king's shadow now how
else can black win
well if black puts his king in there
then he moves the rook in queens
right so those are black's two winning
ideas
so whatever you come up with with white
has to play
against those two ideas here to uh to
solve the study
well storm gd under fide rules i believe
if black were to flag in this position
white would be granted
a full point victory
of course because the g pawn could
promote to a knight
and then black could checkmate himself
in a corner
everybody knows everybody knows that one
and yes so the solution if you want to
not spoil it for yourself go ahead pause
now
as someone has said in the chat is to
play the move bishop f3
this is the only move that prevents
black's plan of coming
to f2 how does it do it well the only
way to make progress
you can't move this rook otherwise the
pawn will fall
you have to play king b2 white's play is
very simple from here on out
you have to stay in front of the king
and at the end of the day
king can step back but we'll just repeat
king e1
king e3 king f1
and now black would love to play the
move
rook h1 but he just doesn't have time
bishop e2 check
key one bishop f3 and
draw and so i thought that was a really
fun puzzle
that i wanted to end on um i do want to
mention
that um
uh of course once again i got most of
these or some of these positions
actually i think like
maybe four of them were from this book
comprehensive chess endings that's what
i'm reading these days
and a lot of the stuff with the check
mating positions
in the pure rook versus bishop stuff was
originally found
by horwitz and kling back in 1851
and then that position with the d-pawn
was actually from philidor way back in
1777.
wanted to throw those out there to make
sure i gave some credit
to where those positions were coming
from that is going to do it for the end
game class here tonight
hopefully you guys learned everything
that you ever wanted to know
and some stuff you didn't want to know
about rooks versus bishops
in these pure end games with no pawns or
one pawn for the attacking side
that is going to do it for us here
tonight as always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you
next time
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]